You can tell a lot about a person just from
their hair.
Like I can look at you and know if you’re
bald just like that.
Hi everyone, Julian for DNews.
A person’s hair reveals a lot of secrets
about them, and you can uncover them.
Not by interpreting clumps of human hair with
pilimancy or some other form of heresy, but
with science.
I’m going to wager you’ve seen the detective
shows where they find a single hair at the
crime scene, extract the DNA from it, find
the murderer, and then David Caruso puts on
his sunglasses and says something like, “He
almost got away with it but he was just a…
hair short.”
It’s true that hair can be used to pull
a DNA sample, but it’s a lot harder than
those shows make it seem.
See, most of your hair is dead cells.
When they die they are pressed together to
form a protein called keratin and new cells
are generated underneath them by the root.
In the process though, the nucleus inside
the cell gets destroyed and the DNA goes with
it, so usually to get a hair sample with any
useful DNA, it has to have the root attached.
Rarely some DNA will survive cornification,
but finding hair at a crime scene is not the
smoking gun it’s always made out to be.
Incomplete hair may help determine maternal
lineage though.
Because mitochondrial DNA is passed from mother
to offspring and is thousands of times more
abundant than nuclear DNA, it’s easier to
get a sample to analyze.
But even without the root, hair can be full
of secrets.
Keratin has sulfur atoms that bond to trace
elements, which explains why Trace is so hairy.
Anyway these elements can give away what you’ve
been putting in your body.
I know a lot of you immediately thought about
drugs.
And it’s true, drug tests can find out if
someone’s been using marijuana or opiates
or amphetamines or PCP.
And since those elements bind to your hair
when the hair is forming, the longer your
hair, the farther back the test goes.
So if you’re a hippy with dreads finally
applying for that big government job, that’s
another reason to get a haircut.
Don’t think shaving your head bald will
help either, because your hair is everywhere,
screaming infidelities.
Like your body hair.
Drug tests can use that too, and since body
hair doesn’t grow like the hair on your
head, it could actually represent a longer
timeframe, possibly up to a year, though there
are no conclusive studies on that.
Either way though, it hurts your chances of
passing a drug test if you’re a hairy pothead.
Interestingly it takes about 5 to 7 days for
forming hair to start protruding past the
scalp, so you could do a bunch of drugs and
pass a hair drug test that same day.
But, y’know, don’t do a bunch of drugs.
Please.
Keratin’s tendency to grab trace elements
can be used to divine more mundane things
too.
It can tell us what someone’s diet is.
This fact makes it useful for studying animals
like bears.
Researchers have actually developed a new
technique that runs a laser down the length
of a single bear hair and vaporizes it.
The gas is then analyzed by a mass spectrometer.
The old method involved analyzing bunches
of hair which gave them a general idea of
what they had been eating.
Doing it this way lets them easily tell exactly
when their diets change and monitor how much
mercury they’re getting from fish.
Plus I imagine it’s safer running up and
plucking one hair off a grizzly than grabbing
entire handfuls.
So, the eternal question still stands: does
she or doesn’t she dye her hair?
Only her hairdresser knows for sure.
Unless it’s blue, then we can all tell,
because blue almost never happens in nature.
Trace explains why here.